how does a character arrive for
screenwriters is it something that's
very vivid in their mind like almost
this is a real person even if it's not
or is it a hazy
vague thing that develops over many
drafts i think it
ultimately it's going to depend on the
writer and i've known writers that work
they have a great character and they
just want to see what kind of
circumstance would be right for this
character to explore in fact frank
danielle
used to say that you could see a story
as like a scientific experiment where
you take a
known substance and a environment that
you know and you put them together and
see how they react
find out what happens you want to find
a charac some people will go with that
first okay this great character what
kind of circumstance would
challenge them the most make them
explode basically
um and but most people tend to come up
with a story
i find first and then they explore well
what kind of character
can can that be um
would work for my story that i have and
in terms of how right different writers
work
i i know some writers will
base it on a person they know and
sometimes that's very useful
um and uh the advantage of that
even if the the person they know has
nothing to do with that kind of story
is that you can get real specific
because you know the character you know
you know them how they
are and you're not gonna they're not
gonna they're capable of some things
they're not capable of other things
um but uh so um
but i've been in a situation where i
based a script on a person who was in
the story
and then at the end of the draft i was
like that's not the right person for
that story
so i wound up going through i called it
a major characterectomy
changed that i bet that hurt right well
actually it worked out in the end i'm
good okay
um but uh so
yeah so different writers have different
processes but
the the key for me is make it specific
as you can
you don't i do have students who'll say
joe
19 is a typical freshman it's like
there's no typical freshman there's no
typical anything everybody's everybody's
unique and you look for that but
so yeah that's that's been been my
experience of it
what about the science of connecting to
character right
that is um again something that that we
dedicate a chapter to um one
term that gets used that i think can
limit imagination is the idea of a hero
a hero we talk about the hero's journey
and then people say well
if i got a hero the connotation of a
hero
is someone who's heroic someone who's
likable and does brave things that's not
necessarily what's meant by the hero's
journey
but that's the connotation that people
have and
the fact is that people tend to like
to watch people with flaws and you don't
want to
eliminate that you have people that
aren't necessarily admirable
in fact uh one theory we talked about
a a a psychologist named
jonathan gotcha has a book on this is
that um
that we watch
characters who are flawed because we
learn from them um
that that again quoting i can get you
the exact
psychologist who said it he said
that stories are flight simulators for
life
like you can a flight simulator so you
can make mistakes and not die
and a story is watching other people
make mistakes
so you can learn to not do those things
and so
it's the question of does your character
have to be likable
well the answer is it's all about what's
called the primacy effect
first impressions if they're
the example of uh jp mcmurphy
okay in the cuckoo's nest how likable
is someone who's committed statutory
rape who's
uh gets into fights all the time and is
in jail and slacks off and doesn't want
to work just wants to play cards
you tell someone no i got this character
i don't want to spend time with that
character
that's who he is but
when you first meet him
he's not doing those things when you
first meet him he's like being released
and he's like
whooping up for joy and then he's out
there hanging out with people
and trying to encourage people looking
at their cards and things
so our first impression of them is that
and that allows us to bond with him
and then as the course of the story we
get to see
his flaws come out and how they play
into the circumstance
um that movie um in bruges is the same
thing
you know you have a character who's
who's a hired killer and he killed a
little kid
by accident but he still he killed a kid
and now he's he's wondering what to do
but you don't know that
when you first meet him he's like a
little boy complaining that he's stuck
in this place looking at museums and
there's a dark side to it
but we get to know him that way and then
we gradually
learn about him and by then we're on his
side so
um but the question of connecting to a
main character
is what exactly happens we talk about it
again
in the book there are different theories
um
there is this idea of course that you
like a character so you sympathize with
them
but there's also a theory that you you
become the character
that you literally go through a process
uh that
one theorist argues is the basis for
morality
that you go through the process where
you can feel the pain that the other
person feels
like the example given is a person
decides a woman decides he's going to
murder the old man next door and then
imagines what it'd be like to be
murdered and then imagines that they are
the one being murdered he feels the pain
and says no i'm not going to do that so
that it's
more than just liking a character
it's actually a process by which you
merge and become
emotionally connected there's another i
don't know if we talked about this in
the book but
there's this notion of mirror neurons
too in the brain
that the that looking at a
chocolate pie looking at someone eating
a chocolate
pie fires the same pleasure neurons in
your brain
as you eating it so that you that's
not subtle science i guess yet but there
are
strong connections that that audiences
make with
with the character that allows them to
go on this journey and and
purge themselves you know of emotion as
aristotle said
many years ago and i think it's a
this this poses a challenge oddly enough
for virtual reality because virtual
reality a few years ago
they're really struggling to come up
with a way to make it a mass consumption
product like
a hit like you have jaws or star wars or
at the movie theater you'll have a
similar thing going on with uh
public theater where they're playing
doing something and the problem with
that is that
you when you surrender to a movie
character
you're surrendering you're not there
anymore you stop existing
now you don't have agency you don't do
anything
you're just watching it and you're
enthralled and you are
it but if you're in virtual reality you
still have agency
you're not the person there you're
actually making decisions
so you're inevitably pulled out of it
and great for a game i'm i'm glad they
haven't
developed them too far because i'd be
addicted and i'd never do anything but
play
virtual reality games it's wonderful but
this process of audience connection with
a character whether it's in movies or
a storyteller is
involves real close connection and
therefore
learning and you uh see a character
go through what we call character arc
that's when they become consciously
aware of
something they didn't know before and
it's a lesson they they have to learn
or you have a tragedy where the
character
never learns but we learned that they
did something that they couldn't recover
from they didn't learn in time
or you get something really twisted like
cuckoo's nest where the character is
heroic
and we don't want him to learn we want
him to always be heroic it's just that
it's a tragedy what happened but
something else happens so there's
there's variations um
on that